Miley Cyrus Caitlin Carter and Miley's
mom Tish have a girls day on like the
luckiest ever the trio was photographed
heading to lunch together in LA on
Saturday as Miley and Caitlin continue
to spend time together back in the
States
check out this photo of Tish driving a
black SUV while Miley rides Shani on
their way to Boas steakhouse on Sunset
Boulevard in a second snap Caitlin can
be seen exiting the car with Tish who
rocked a gray t-shirt and jeans while
Caitlin looked cute in a white t-shirt
pink polkadot skirt and white tennis
shoes
[Music]
the lunch date comes one week after the
wrecking ball singer and the hills new
beginning star were spotted kissing in
Italy just hours before Miley announced
her separation from hubby Liam Hemsworth
a source told ET on Thursday that the
women are both newly out of their
relationships and just having fun of
course Caitlyn split from Brody Jenner
earlier this month and the source went
on to explain quote really only time
will tell if Miley and Caitlyn will last
but right now they are being a support
for one another during a tough time and
enjoying their time together I think I
can handle it meanwhile Brody was
spotted smooching Josie Canseco after
his concert in downtown LA on Friday
that same day he took to Instagram
making it clear there's no bad blood
between him and his ex writing quote
there is far too much negativity being
directed as someone who I love and care
about very much I feel the need to set
the story straight Caitlin and I have
been best friends for six years and we
continue to be we like many others
before us and many after us grew in
different directions over those same six
years as for Miley she just dropped an
emotional new song called slide away
[Music]
change your life worthwhile
the song appears to be about a painful
breakup
one could argue Miley might even be
singing about Liam meanwhile Liam has
been spotted hanging out with mates in
Byron Bay Australia since his split for
Miley was confirmed